welcome to
from the darkness from the darkness of
your soul from the darkness of n4p comes
a demon
in the night i don't know why i'm being
so dramatic welcome to from the darkness
it's a horror game with play new
[Music]
god
the scariest choice of them all play or
new game i feel like these
play
oh hell yeah
um
i really know nothing about this there's
very little pretense to it so it is just
from the darkness
objective get into the 64th apartment of
the deceased grandfather
of my deceased grandfather or just
the
deceased grandfather
ding dong
i can't read that
well that's not very helpful how can i
help find a person if i can't see who
they are left home and did not return
uh
i don't know centimeters
everyone can help well i can't all right
whatever what happens if i go down i
can't go down i better go up then
well sure is dork
i'm going in
there's nothing
okay
whatever you say i'm just going to plow
up
i'm assuming that there's nothing that
i'm going in
one of these days lixian is going to put
something scary in there
don't know what oh
i'm assuming that because this is an
apartment people live here
there's nothing to be worried about i'm
going in
i don't like that
what is that
you know what i'm gonna go with no
i'm going in
okay
oh it's dork
i see
i see
i can't crouch can i
okay
i'm going in
oh god
okay i'm spooked
i'm a i'm a big boy enough to admit it
63 isn't this the one
whoa okay it was just open
but what is more up
i need 64 apartments
don't we all bud don't we all all right
64. dear neighbor if you don't stop
making noise at night we will call the
police oh i have the key
i'm uh
oh i thought it was like a loading
screen ah
hello
hello
the apartment has long been abandoned by
a dead grandfather
the dead grandfather
it's a key
oh that's a coat i really hope that's a
coat
god that better be a coat
no electricity okay well i ain't going
in
that better be a coat in boots
i better be booting coats
ah
that was for that
do i have electricity now
pick up the family album and leave
something tells me i'm not going to be
able to do that
something tells me there's going to be
something getting in my way from doing
that
yum chili
why
what is this that's a picture of a face
lixie and enhance
zoom enhance enhance some more my god
it's you
or not i don't know
[Music]
okay
well
this is great
nope close close close it close it let's
close that and never go in there
oh good
good good good good i was hoping oh hi
okay
well this is disturbing
is that grandpa
what why
no
no
i don't want to
well time to leave
oh
oh no
oh no
okay
we're back in business baby
oh no
no
no why can't there be more light
switches in here
is that somebody there
do i see something i'm coming for you
yeah oh there was someone there
they must been afraid of me
and my power
hello
nice rug on the wall
tv not working not that i care
hey i have feet okay
where's this family album i've heard so
much about
oh well apparently that's the scary room
i why i see you i see you i see you i
see i see
where i find that too dark you know what
probably for the best i'm gonna go with
too dark
okay what do we have here
hello that's weird
missing part i mean missing part
i have a key
for what
yeah i know you're there
i see you
ah trust me i see you
lixian enhance
yep
i see you right key
ah
[Music]
handy
handy dandy
oh
i couldn't have been good
okay well i i got us
oh god
oh god
ah interesting well i got the missing
part
hey i'm just gonna close this i'm gonna
close that i'm gonna close that
i don't know why there's a people on
that door
oh
my shoe flew off wow
hello baby
hey hello handsome how you doing yeah
what a swagger you got
all right albums this is what i'm here
for
well that's not very helpful
what do you have to say about that baby
okay
and they're really coming from the
darkness you know okay so if you're
saying get out there
hmm
hmm
okay that's fine i see a key or a lock
ah
wow an incredibly complex lock
that's normal
that's very normal
you're very normal this is all very
normal
well i'm gonna leave now
still nothing up there
no thank you
why are you doing that
what are you doing
what's with the what's with all of that
[Music]
okay
i still don't want to go in there
why are you doing this to me
i don't want to go up there
i don't want to go i oh stop that
stop stop it stop it
oh hi
oh
good
hello
oh
hey
[Applause]
thank you
objective get out but why though
but
all
[Music]
big
right
big man
big man
all right well my objective uh dive out
the window uh oh bars they literally
thought of everything
there's bars on the window oh
oh no
there's bars on all the windows oh no
oh
okay
[Music]
can you stop doing that
who's ringing
hello
ah of course of course i can't get
through there from there
hello
stop that
i don't hear the ringing anymore
stop it
oh is that a wall of flesh
is that your standard ah it's real dark
now say your standardized wall of flesh
shift to run i i uh okay
that's a little dramatic
oh
oh that's fine
that's what you would call fine um
well howdy doody neighbor how are you uh
how are you how you feeling how are you
doing how you i've my my i'm being
pulled in i'm being
don't mean to interrupt your meal or
whatever you're doing in there uh fap
session oh you know we all need fresh
relief someday but um
thank you
hey how you doing
yeah i'm just gonna close that
hello
[Music]
fine
oh it's a radio it's a radio in the
other room it's a radio in the baby room
did you hear the radio oh oh
oh big hand
uh
oh okay
oh
uh
hey pal
ah
[Music]
well
this is
delightful i'm just gonna
just gonna do that
terrible okay
well those are now done for
what you doing over here
grandpa
is that you
hello
god i can't see nothing
i don't know
oh hey big guy how are you doing wow
it's gonna go in here
[Music]
we're not
okay excuse me i need to turn this
ah there we go
oh nope
and we're back here
okay
good good good
oh you
hi
oh
that's an ear man grandpa's got some
explaining to do that's a finger
yeah graham
grampy's got some explaining to do
safety safe perfectly safe now
[Laughter]
okey dokey
well well well what the hell do i do
with this
ah here we go
oh damn it it was already perfect
it was glowing and everything
[Music]
i can hot
oh
water
i'm guessing that might have been a red
herring
but also
very cruel joke
i'm guessing it was just a goof oh
green
[Music]
whatever that is well that's andy okay
green smooble
so that means there are other symbols
i'm going down
[Music]
do i have to get up and turn that on i
probably do
well this is fine
it's gonna close that
okay green schmoobles ah blue m
so green schmooble's blue m
oh wow that's red
oh
oh red martini glass okay that's good
green schmoobles with the hornies and
then red martini glass blue m
and
maybe uh the last one could be process
of elimination
so red was the martini glass that's all
right there we go and then green was the
shmoogly horns blue was the m and then
yellow i process of elimination
hell yeah
hell yeah broham
finally this is worse it's worse it's
worse you're worse how'd you get worse
oh my god you're worse why are you worse
so what is wrong with you
what happened to you what happened to
you why are you like this stop looking
at me like that
oh what happened to me oh no what's
wrong with my face oh no
all right let's go for it i'm ready
are you alright
you okay
oh no
oh
ah
[Music]
god they really nailed the flashlight
look holy hell
uh oh
f for me oh no oh no don't type f in the
comments oh no
f
[Music]
here i did
here
oh
[Music]
voice in total darkness i buried him in
concrete you did not hear
[Music]
oh now i hear sounds go to the voice in
total
[Music]
i
gotcha this is bad i hate this
[Music]
oh
okay i gotta go in total darkness right
okay in total darkness got it
this is great this is great it's so good
this room stinks of a corpse
well
that's okay
because it's dark and stuff
oh good
oh
what's happening i can't see anything
should i look i shouldn't look what am i
doing
what's happening
i'm gonna turn on the light
eye
finger eye teeth
key
finger eye teeth key
where are you moving stop moving finger
eye teeth key
finger idiki
he doesn't like light who doesn't
oh god
so there was a finger in there
perfect
perfect oh
perfect
what about in the gumbo
oh
i hate this can i just say i really hate
this this is actually terrifying and i'm
speaking to you out loud and and because
i feel alone and i am uh not comfortable
being alone
and your eye teeth key
finger right key okay
i don't remember seeing on eye in the
doll
in the doll i don't know where teeth
would be maybe my own maybe i could pull
out my own with the pliers
aren't there pliers in here can i pull
them out my own
pliers right there
i could do it i'd do it to get out to
get a key oh you know i'd do it
oh
oh that's new
okay hey can i borrow some things
you mind
you mind
oh right yep i knew it the pliers i was
gonna do it i was ready for it and now i
don't have to do it to myself so uh
that's even better that's like bonus
points
that's that
so much better
excuse me pal
i'll be taking those hey
ah i'm really efficient
you got an eyeball
no eyeballs eyes are gone
yeah it makes sense that makes sense
yeah am i oh okay that's weird
i feel like this is a distraction
in here hello it's super dark in there
i'm guessing i'm not supposed to go
there ah
you got a
eyeball or something
cool my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
oh
oh kill anybody that jumps out of me
he
all right easy peasy
i'll be on my way then i hated that
i bet it goes to the thing in here
yep
oh
don't worry i'm reading between the laws
you want me to take care of that baby
oh don't you worry
i'm gonna take care of it
real good
baby
where you at baby you hide no baby yeah
i can eat
i need to borrow some from you
thank you
yeah it's fine
all right
i'm on my way
drowning in success here just really
here you go
uh oh
that is not how i expected that to go
he is stronger in the dark when you
light up all the rooms it will get
weaker and you can get out this is the
key to the box under the ceiling i'm
sorry
uh
what
uh what
the
oh
don't mind me
nothing to set fire to the candle well
that's a problem isn't it
that's a problem in it when there are
matches somewhere here
i saw i thought i saw a box of matches
didn't i
oh that's not good
oh this is what you call bad
matches are these matches i don't know
uh what do russian matches look like i
don't know hey big guy you seen any
matches
hey kid
oh you know but i don't want to
uh but you know about it i i don't
really want to answer that
whatever that may be
guy man got a light hey you got a light
there pal
you listen to me buddy all right
hey
hey
why you got me like that
why god do me like that neighbor could i
borrow a like
oh
good
oh great what's oh
good
well that's not right
that's not right at all
huh six huh
hey neighbor
get out borrow uh
light
thumb to
match lighter
oh hey bud
i'm sorry i'm
i'm sorry grandpa is that you
grampy okay
[Music]
not gonna question
i got a question
not gonna question it
you need to listen do i
try again oh
i need to listen apparently
i will try again
i didn't do it right did i
well damn it so it must be coming from
below me
oh yeah wait no
this is five
this is five okay all right grampy um
okay
what if i go down
oh eyes man i was looking all over for
you before no you're right here
hello
i'm listening
oh [ __ ]
god damn it
you've already come from here for the
for the fourth time nothing will change
you don't know that hey you don't know
that
hey you don't know me
hey
come on now
you think you know me if sounds are
heard outside the door it is better do
not oh
oh
[Music]
oh
i was thinking the opposite ah that that
makes sense
that oh
that's a little
grandpa long
so if there are noises there then that
means
ah
go back the way you came
i see
oh
fun
i hear you
okay that's blocked off okay
definitely hear something over there
that sounds worse
so i have to go up
that's weird oh hi
okay weird
ah
this
what does that do
ah nothing
[Music]
ah
nothing
ah interesting
i made it okay it took a little bit of
doing but i got there
i got there don't worry everybody i got
there okay and then arms in the elevator
that's perfectly normal
that sounds bad
can barely see anything anymore
oh god
oh god
oh
freedom
yeah buddy into the endless landscape of
nothingness friend and eternity i can't
go forward uh
hello what is that over there lixian
zoom
enhance
my god
i don't know what it is
hmm
seems like i must have slept into
another dimension at some point here
so
it's to go back in
sounds quiet to me i can't go ahead
never mind not quite
whoa
hey hey belle
hello ah let me join you grandpappy
grandpappy grant grandpappy
v the lighter
grandpappy did you just give that to me
grampy
that's awfully sweet of you
a very nice
why would you do that
why would you do something like that i'm
guessing i go up
music awfully
schwombly
oh hi hey what's up pal
hey how you doing hey good to see you um
so
thanks for the lighter really appreciate
that
you are uh
a big help yeah i just gotta say that
you're a big help
thank you
thank you so much
for uh
getting me through this it's good to
have a friend in the brain levator
you work in the brain levator okay i'll
be going now
later
all right let's light some candles
let's light this bad boy up
[Music]
oh
god to light up the lights in all the
rooms
okay aha
perfect
perfect
well this is easy
wham
just that simple
oh
oh
that's not good
what
my objective my my objective my
objective
my objective what's outside my objective
my my objective uh my objective
oh
ah excuse me sorry i have an objective
back to the objective
just gonna
put can't forget about this room
very important
well i can't like that person there we
go
oh my objective
uh my objective
my uh my objective
oh
ah oh no
this is uh i hide under the bed
yes
god i'm smart
okay apparently that's not working um
well
hi
how you doing
hey
you up thanks for the teeth by the way
by the bye
oh wait here
oh
okay goodbye
oh ah hi hello oh
hi hey what's up pals
[Music]
back to the objective
objective
all right
hey
stop it whoa hey whoa whoa hey whoa
cut that [ __ ] out
i worked very hard at making that happen
all right the objective continues
hey you mind holding this
okay didn't mean to get that close right
on the twin there we go ass good stuff
that's a good stuff
it's a good stuff all right oh
no not again
oh this is tension
pretentious
okay back to the objective
and where's that baby
oh that's weird
well
that
that don't seem good
hope that don't happen to me
i remember my objective i remember you
think i don't remember my objective of
course i do of course
knock knock hello who's there me
let me in
[Music]
uh i can't seem to get in that room
there
sure would love to get in there
for my objective
i'm uh not sure what i need to do
ah
there we go
now we're good somehow that had gotten
turned off
or blown out
and now my objective shall be complete
uh slam wham
take that
defeated
yeah you should have tried ardor bell i
am out of here
better luck next time
you really thought you had me but uh i
was going easy on you i'll get you
around later gramps
all right gramps i'll see you on the
flippity flip
pal
buddy
family
uh
man
i'm just gonna run a little faster now
oh i'm gonna run a little faster
can't wait to
run a little faster now it seems to be
oh no
ah well maybe that's just how the
weather always has been around here
that was great
that was really
really well done
that was one of the most scary like
straightforward just horror things that
i've had in a very long time it created
a sense of dread that i have not had in
a very long time
it was
very
good really well done and the thing
about it was as you could probably see
that it wasn't really all that refined
but it had
pizzazz and look there's another one by
the same person can't wait to play that
one this could be good that was very
good very very fun it's been a while
since i played a really nice
self-contained little horror experience
like that really really good stuff
though if you want to see more scary
games that i've played link is in the
description huge playlist tons of stuff
check it out there's something you'll
like if you like that and want something
a little less scary why not check out
distractable or go my favorite sports
team my podcast with tyler and bob and
wade links in the description thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]